see I'm doing my PhD as I've been
introduced as in physics and
specifically I'm looking at stratosphere
troposphere couple and you might have
heard of the fact that the atmosphere
like my ovaries like onions have layers
and each of these layers have quite
distinct dynamics and the language which
we live in the troposphere
is just one and I'm going to be talking
to you about them their strategy
I'm sort of 23 whining about I should
probably say the stuff this is real
physics right a lot of people dismiss
this kind of thing as geography but the
study the the study of the atmosphere is
ultimately the study of the physical
system it's the greatest experiment on
earth you know it's it's combination of
physics and maths and chemistry and in
order to understand what's gonna happen
in the future we need to apply physics
what's happening that so that's what I'm
gonna start talking about basically
introducing the kind of business that we
use and then specifically which
particular part of this makes this has
their ways then how will happen in the
stratosphere which is ultimately tens of
contours above our heads and directly at
that web service so well with the
atmosphere you might have heard of it
it's quite useful keeps us alive keeps
us warm
to give you a sense of what kind of
physical system with dealing with it's
actually quite difficult to describe
where the atmosphere stops because the
density goes exponentially with height
so you have to reach a cutoff point you
say well that's enough there's nobody
much molecules supposed to call it an
atmosphere anymore one definition is 600
kilometers above the surface that's the
point at which radiation constants when
you hear people saying there's so many
watts received at the earth per square
means that that's why that's expressed
it's also the top of the thermosphere
which is another one of those massive
but that definition is a little bit
tricky because near as you can see here
I think that's near yeah I mean it's
National Space Station they both all bit
about for any clothes about the
observers so well within the atmosphere
the space community tend for the
definition of the common language it's
100 kilometers above the Earth's surface
and that's above the meter speed which
is the other layer above the
stratosphere and that's sort of if you
want to think about the atmosphere in
terms of how big we're dealing with
that's
pretty good estimate a planetary system
about 100 clauses tool compare that with
the Earth's radius of 6,400 kilometers
and you're leaving with a very small
fraction the size of year it has a
massive difference on our lives at the
surface and even that hundred kilometer
such a point out because it goes
exponentially it's really only the very
bottom 10 to 20 kilometers that it has a
noticeable effect so he would have a
glow the atmospheres the thickness of
the layer of varnish it's very very thin
system I'll tell you what it's comprised
of it's mostly nitrogen a bit of oxygen
but the point is its absolute right we
describe the physics of the atmosphere
as a fluid to means the same equations
that we used to describe water will oil
or pitch and anybody who is taking the
30 of course in fluid mechanics will
recognize its famous equation where V is
the velocity vector the pressure term
kinematic dynamic thing and then this is
a forcing term which includes the
Coriolis force it's obviously very
important on earth the earth spinning
lends an awful lot of dynamics which and
the system is there with an animal all
engine you know derives from the Sun and
so in order to drive the system we well
you have to use an understanding so if
anybody hasn't taken the second-year
course this is just setting the table
energy change in the system is equal to
the 80 plus the word apply so work for
example might be piston and Ione so
that's that's basically plus that's
that's the system in a nutshell it's
only 19th century physics it's pretty
easy you know well it's very much very
complicated system nobody solving are
these those equations exactly for one
thing so you can't do have a general
solution out there and also because it's
a chaotic system meaning that if you
have a small measure measurements wind
velocity or temperature you can't
predict more than 10 days in a part even
it doesn't matter how how do computers
because it's a chaotic system anybody
again any stuff is very difficult no you
will predict acutally massively
different from so
the section of the atmosphere that we
live I said before is called atrocity
and it's typify by the fact that so it's
defined whether that that when you get
higher up it gets colder you know if you
don't see people climbing Mount Everest
in flip-flops or white shorts and I just
found that little paradoxical the kid
this idea that when you get close to the
Sun in the day actually gets cold but
the the fact is that the air above the
earth isn't heated brother slept heated
by the earth so in simple terms the Sun
emits shortwave radiation very hot body
a certain it's awful lot of energy and
it does that high-energy photons a short
wavelength the answer is basically
transparent so this kind of radiation
doesn't absorb anything the fact that
some substances absorb radiation has set
frequencies of determine quantum
mechanically that's just the whole
letter in itself you just have to take
it on trust that because the air is the
nitrogen and oxygen for the most part it
doesn't interact with the shortwave
radiation at all when it doesn't rappin
is the long-wave radiation so the
airport taking this energy and it'll be
radiated because it's really a ting a
much lower temperature than the Sun
radiates as long-wave radiation there's
energy and this energy is then absorbed
by the a mass of up the O so if you take
this cubic meter of air above the earth
then the radiation which is coming into
it it will take a certain percentage of
that it's not completely transparent and
then it's the what's left will pardon
excuse me to do that and that keeps
happening and every time a cube meter
absorbs from that radiation the signal
is a tenuous so you get less heat
propagating it through the atmosphere so
because there's less energy going into
each CUNY equilibrates a lower
temperature so you know if you have
always wanted to do this I don't
actually need to do this but i doesn't
and this tax change is
at the point where the temperature stops
decreasing you to get higher up it's
about minus 50 degrees Celsius it's
actually pretty cold and we call this
point via the troubles this is boundary
between the troposphere and the
stratosphere and well the time you get
to the top of the stress it's about zero
degrees Celsius maybe minus five degrees
that's it so this is a significant about
anything so what's causing this well I
said before that the atmosphere is
transparent to shortwave radiation but
the Sun gives off and that's true for
the most part because most of the
atmosphere is diatomic molecules it's a
nitrogen oxygen a significant factor the
Stratus bits are not that I've chosen
now though so neither don't notice three
oxygen atoms stuck together in its form
when a very very high energy photon will
strike into
diatomic oxygen split apart and they'll
combine with other molecules and ozone
will absorb high-energy photons if
they're easy you've probably heard of
ozone because of the ozone net right
this idea that we can destroy those in
there with CFCs and by doing that we get
all UV radiation that service and
everyone dies asking after fortunately
this is actually a great success story
now andropause the party knows only it's
actually healing itself quite nicely
because the montreal protocol protocol
puff and we stopped polluting absolute
well what happened is this ocean will
take him one of these photons is UV
potent will split it into atomic oxygen
and diatomic oxygen and in doing that it
gets these two products more kinetic
energy than the ozone molecule have to
start with so you get these two more
dynamic more and the macroscopic effects
at more atomic motion is an increase in
temperature
that's all temperature it's the
microscopic effect of the microscopic
motion and so this heating in that
drives this change in temperature as you
get higher up now this means the
stratosphere has very different dynamics
not the experience on that but I
actually do
so let's consider this is just a basic
bit phone for that let's say that we
have two ladies who do you want and we
use the ideal gas equation so that the
pressure is equal to the density
multiplied by the gas constant of the
temperature we're going to rearrange it
to be density now let's consider an
airport at this temperature and when I
say our possible I mean it's like if you
were to just have an infinitely thin
balloon you blow it up and that there
the at exactly the same pressure and
density and temperature and it's just a
convenient way of sort of holding on to
a particularly they're there and let's
say this gets this place that this and
this could be by a plane moving through
in it and it pushes it out the way with
its way in you might be that it's
fumbling when it hits a mountain it gets
pushed up doesn't matter but let's get
let's say this gets moved up to this
there now could it see to but it's still
attempt to team one now
if let's say we're in the troposphere
let's say that this is up some Mountain
somewhere and the density of this air
passes the same set is down here so it's
density is the pressure divided by RT
and because the temperature is higher at
the original position that means that
its density is less than the density of
the air that it's been thrust up into
all right what this means then is that
you've got a fluid with left hand used
to run by the fluid lots of with a high
density in exactly the same way but if
you were to blow an air bubble
underwater and assuming that bubble
rises up it's got less density
this happens in yeah this has been huge
shooting up some other things to stop it
until it hits the top and this is what
gives the the trucks here its name drop
off green turning it's dynamically
unstable now instead let's consider what
happens in the stratosphere so if we do
this exactly the same thing we displace
the third part new temperature except
this temperature is now higher which
means this is an air parcel which is
denser than its surroundings
so what this does it sends back to a
separate living position exactly the
same thing happens if you to defend it
you to push it back on the stratosphere
Stratus is stratified it means that it's
very boring dynamically to be actually
boring them but it's it's it's
completely different from what we
experienced on the surface and we can
see how different quite really cool and
this this looks like visualize the
climate data in real time so this is a
map of the Earth's velocity the wind
blows to right now and if you do this
fitting close to you that you can
attempt pressure so you can see that
we've got you can see that we've got
depression heat we've got a depression
he has got two depressions there you can
see you can see flow cycling around
there and you can see there's a lot
interesting thing happening just below
Sicily there's something happening over
Russia North America there's a lot going
on right let's zoom out and the other
cool thing about website Alessi looking
at four different layers so this is the
troposphere this is the survey let's
look at stratosphere and you'll notice
by the way this isn't pressure it will
define thinking after it by pressure of
appliances it's very different
so remember about the orders of tens of
kilometers per hour at 350 sponsors
proud this is the polar vortex that
everyone's heard loads about and this is
the defining feature of the winter the
Northern Hemisphere winter circulation
this it's much simpler we get big big
grow structures and this is only in
winter by the way if we look at all the
year this people
so it's very very different
and because the atmosphere sitting up
there as long as seems to be basically
like an add-on atrocity is forced by the
troposphere you know things like
planetary waves that are caused by
mountains and propagate up there and
they do something there's something
called the quasi final oscillation big
view of the Equator with bands of
descending winds but they don't get the
food so it wasn't really until nineteen
fifties and sixties where people
actually started wondering maybe the
stratosphere is they need to do well sir
so how could the stratosphere Fetzer
there's a few ways in which it can do it
and I'm going to talk about this briefly
these are mass exchange finally wave
reflection which is important not quite
pollutant induced Marine mean Meridian
circulation where it's complicated and
the sending vortex allotments which is
what's what my research is the first one
of these mass exchange this isn't this
is a figured easy
no what we're looking at is the position
of the tropical so you remember that the
trouble pause it's this distinction
between the troposphere and stratosphere
right so the difference between is to
Beijing and that's the thick lower line
that and varies the equator is actually
quite high
that's that's because there's the
equator getting radiation with the earth
spinning and it goes down to about seven
kilometers this grey region is areas
where the technical definition is this
areas where lines of constant potential
temperature intercept both the
stratosphere and the troposphere what it
means is that air masses conflict
between the two because mass movements
are conserved on these these surfaces
and because they enter cut both the
stratosphere and troposphere you you can
get matter moving between two and this
was discovered in the fifties and
sixties with a very morbid reason and
that's that both Soviet and American
scientists wanted to know if you
detonated a nuclear warhead and blew
loads of radioactive matter and fallout
into the Earth's atmosphere if you blue
line up into the stratosphere could it
go all the way around the world going
back into the troposphere and then land
on your city and that was if you look at
these papers as horrifying I did a
search on all these papers in the 50 to
60 well it's initially just the time
like nuclear fallout in the stratosphere
and they're working on whether it will
come down south well that's one example
another example is ozone so I said that
there's this ozone layer in the
stratosphere is what causes the
stratosphere to have its turn up and it
was an unfortunate unpleasant health
effects that you breathe it and it
smells like magnolias but it causes you
spiritual but um yeah it causes some
unpleasant effects and it's what happens
when you get smoked get for solar sighs
so in Los Angeles one of the big
problems are small UV radiation hits it
but equally stupid kills ozone makes it
from the troposphere and stratosphere so
the CFCs I was talking about before this
is sort of how they the nice thing
finally a reflection I promised this a
bit let's cool it out is that what we're
looking at here is the jet stream so
this is the path and midway through up
the troposphere which sort of dictates
where a lot of northern hemisphere
weather goes and it's an example of a
planetary scale away it's an oscillation
in wind and these waves they just
propagate horizontally they also
propagate vertically and what happens is
they hit the the tropopause and they're
reflected or they can be reflected and
what determines how much is reflected
and whether it gets affected at all is
the shear that happens it's of the
difference in the opportunity in the
stratosphere the troposphere so this was
only considered in the eighties this is
really for some physics that's very very
new you know and what happens is these
leaves then propagate up they found off
the top of the tops the top of the
troposphere and they re interfere with
themselves so you get much more
complicated than acts you know the saws
it is very with itself right okay next
one you just meet me Rhydian
let me get that right one day this is a
little bit drier but it is kind of cool
what we're looking at here is this gray
region is this is a theoretical solution
this is an actual data coordinate the
it's basically if you had a small room
and you kind of fan on at the top what
happens is you get circulation forming
and even if there's a even if you were
two distinct the two layers
doesn't matter look into some small
level of circulation that's what this is
basically talking about this plan shows
I was talking about before they
propagate up into the truck the
stratosphere and they break like waves
on a beach break and they deposit
momentum on a beach that the momentum is
deposited in sits and causes the
sonogram in this case this is a
frictional forces it's a westerly
forcing and what we look at here is a
young a meridian circulation so when I
say that that meridian associations in
fact the earth versus and meridians own
elite symmetric and it's a very weak
effect but this ties in with before this
mixes matter between the mountain tops
for the stratosphere and again this was
really quite recent but most recently
all it's the work which is the line worn
out which is these descending wall
technologies now this is a really cool
figure than my seat bottom I opened it
and what we're looking at is he averaged
the dynamics the polar vortex that big
swirling pattern and considered the
anomalies in that when it was
particularly weak or strong and looked
at what happens when you get very very
strong very very weak for to see what
happens is all of a sudden these sudden
these zonal wind anomalies propagate
down early and they hit the stratosphere
and that's the trouble and they keep
going down to the surface look this
event happened at you know day 0 here
and it's still having a noticeable
effect on the surface of the 60 days
this is sort of more the open questions
we don't know what's doing this we can
statistically look at what's happening
we can actually look at spatially the
temperature effect was happening that
was that was the windows this is
temperature we don't know what mackins
what mechanism is causing this but it
does give us a level of prediction so I
said earlier that you can't predict more
than 10 days into the future
it's CrossFit because it's a chaotic
system with this you can say that for
example the top of the very north of
Europe is going to be significantly
colder than normal if you have a very
weak water and that's for 60 decks that
gives you quite a long level of its
ability that hasn't quite been maximized
yet this was 1999 I also know
papers 1999 this one actually should be
from 2002 and it's still an ongoing area
of research because I often look at
these tools something but something I
think is you telling me this stuff why
are you telling me there's not a
question at the end of it these are the
questions we don't know what's causing
that one theory that my supervisor has
is that the strength of the vortex
actually causes the truck cause to lift
up and it causes a pressure on and
that's not what I'm looking at once I
actually get my program to work that's
what the cones supposed to be doing it's
supposed to be analyzing pressure male
announcer other questions how can we use
that to improve prediction ultimately
there's no point in doing all this
enable gauging and let's actually
improve some of the life and how all the
stratosphere global temperature change
there was a whole chapter on the most
recent IPCC report because it's never
really been considered because the
dynamics weren't really considered
important to the surface the fact that
the UM the stratosphere is cooling
because we've had less disruption the
stratosphere as as cool whilst the rest
of the surface of water and this
question of well what happens when the
ozone goes back anybody can use a four
year by the way anybody okay there's a
guy in your teacher in fourth you if you
do the appletalk which you should all do
sits you know these four one
there's a guy he'll teach you who's
involved in a method of combating
climate change by injecting
aerosols into the stratosphere because
it's it's not overturning like the
troposphere that you can assume these
things are going to stay in this class
here and they'll then reflect excess
solar radiation and there's obviously a
huge number of questions on expert but
that's just saying in addition to being
this sort of roof on the atmosphere as
we know it I'd like to take from this
Hey yeah that's food has different
layers and they're dynamically very
different and that what happens you know
tens of kilometers and hundreds of
clouds is in fact away from us
horizontally has an effect on us exactly
the same way what happens tens of
kilometers bubbles and that they assume
that our experience of the atmosphere is
all there is
so thanks for inviting me and I guess
second question